- [Brent] Great season, everyone.
That finale had me in tears.
- Yes, fantastic.
- Will Smith!
- [Brent] Yes, there he is.
- Fresh Prince himself.
- The man himself.
- Great job, Janet.
That Aunt Viv finger-point you did,
you knocked it out of the ball park.
- Thank you.
- Hey, could we talk to you in my office?
- Yeah, I don't see why not.
- Janet, please have a seat.
Can we get you anything,
coffee, tea, kleenex?
Because you're about to be fired.
- Excuse me?
Fired, what do you mean fired?
- Shhh, calm down, okay?
Mary-Kate and Ashley
are sleeping next door.
- This is ridiculous, what
do you mean I'm fired?
- Production has cue cards for a reason,
you can't just be going off-book.
- You didn't complain when I
went off-book last night, Brent.
- Okay, Janet, I wouldn't
worry even a little bit.
There is tons of acting work out there
for middle-aged African
American women, it's the '90s.
- Oh really, like what?
Name one show.
- Family Matters, that's a show.
- Name another show.
- Step By Step.
- They are all white.
- What, no!
- Cody's like, Filipino or--
- [Brent] Native American.
- [Janet] He's probably the whitest person
that's on the show.
- Oh my god.
Oh my god, there is a huge
diversity problem in television.
Anyway, you're still fired.
- This is out of control, okay?
This show needs me.
What are you gonna do, huh?
Kill me off, make Uncle
Phil a single uncle?
America won't wanna see that.
- Oh, this is so embarrassing for you.
- You think we're gonna kill Aunt Viv?
- Okay so what are you
gonna do, what am I--
- Replaced?
Hi, gentlemen, here's your coffee.
- Thank you, new Aunt Viv.
- New Aunt Viv.
- New Aunt Viv?
Are you joking me right now?
- No, no, we're not the jokesters,
but new Aunt Viv sure is.
- That wasn't an earthquake,
Uncle Phil was jumping rope.
(laughing)
- That is what we're talking
about, that is comedy.
- Are you being serious right now?
We don't even look alike.
- I think you do.
- Yeah, me too.
- Look it, you squint
your eyes and do this.
Which one's which; who are we firing?
- Okay you know what, stop it.
I am a pinnacle in this
show and I can't be replaced
by some wanna-be.
I said a wanna-be.
What's wrong with her?
- Oh, she's a robot.
Now Janet, if you just
wanna grab your things--
- A robot?!
- Yeah well, they're easy to work with
and they don't go off-book.
- It's the new wave, Janet.
- Holly Robinson Peete from
Hangin' with Mister Cooper?
Robot.
- Lisa from Saved by the Bell, robot.
- Dustin Diamond was a person,
replaced him with a robot.
First white robot.
- [Brent] First white robot.
- [Brent] Hey, there he is.
- You know what?
I am not going, okay?
I'm not going anywhere.
Malcom X says a woman
who stands her ground
is a woman that stands tall--
- [Brunette Man] Security!
- Are you kidding me?
You called secur--you know what?
You won't even know Will
Smith's name in five years.
What are you gonna do,
put him in a movie about
an alien invasion where he saves the world
on any given holiday?
Let go of me!
- That's not a bad idea.
- [Brent] Not bad at all.
- [Brent] Hey Carol, did you hear that?
- Write that down.
- New Aunt Viv, do you
know who Malcom X is?
- No, I do not.
- Oh, she's perfect!
- Wanna go to Eddie Bauer
and get some new slacks?
- You know I do!